The joe rogan experience.
What I'm hoping the book will do in the
long run is that it will lead to more
attention being focused on the Americas.
This is a very neglected
area of the world. Uh,
as far as deep and ancient
archeology goes, I'm, it's,
the recent history of the Americas
has been relatively well studied,
but the deep and ancient history has
not been, has not been well studied,
and I think America is going to contain
revelations for us about our story and
about our past.
And I'm serious when I,
when I suggest that America is the most
plausible and the most likely homebase
for a lost civilization. If you're going
to propose a lost civilization, you need,
there are certain preconditions, you need
a, you can't have it on a small island.
There's got to be a large landmass mass
with enormous resources and the ability
for population to grow and for those
resources to be, to be mobilized.
And what I suddenly realized,
you asked earlier why I,
why I started to write this book at all
is what the new evidence is pointing to
is that the Americans have
been wrongly neglected.
That here we have a giant continental
land mass with extraordinary resources
that has just been ruled out of
the story of human civilization.
But once we take account of the fact that
there was a giant cataclysm over North
America 12,000,
800 years ago,
and once we start looking as I do in
America before at the incredible deep
indepth similarities between,
for example,
the religious system of ancient
Egypt and the religious system of the
Mississippi Valley, then you
realize that you're into, uh,
into a global mystery here and that the
answer to that mystery may not at all be
in the old world and may very much
be, uh, in the, in the Americas. See,
it's odd.
I mentioned Mountville earlier on.
It's kind of odd that we should find a,
what is essentially the
ancient Egyptian religion, uh,
manifesting in the
symbolism of Mountville,
the ascent to Orion that
transit to the Milky Way,
the journey along the Milky Way.
Very,
these are very specific
and idiosyncratic ideas.
And what makes it doubly ARD
is Mountville isn't that old.
Mountville as a site is
about a thousand years old.
Ancient Egypt had already been
gone completely from the world, uh,
for at least 600 years
before Manville was created.
The end of ancient Egypt. There's,
there's Mountville and uh,
w w what we're looking at in the
foreground is mount B and we're looking at
mount day and the in the,
in the distance, um, and,
and the complete circle of mounds.
What w what is odd about it is we find
the system of ancient Egyptian ideas in
Manville 500 years after ancient Egypt
has gone from the world. The Romans,
the Romans were the end of ancient
Egypt by 400 ancient Egypt has gone.
Marrickville doesn't even exist then,
but 600 years later it is created and
it manifests the set of ancient Egyptian
ideas.
Clearly it did not get that as a result
of direct transmission from ancient
Egypt unless they were time travelers.
The only way I think it could have got
it is as a result of a legacy passed down
from a much earlier civilization that has
influenced and affected many different
parts of the world and the
characteristics of that civilization,
the shamanistic heart of it, the use
of altered states of consciousness.
The focus on those are amongst the reasons
that I would suggest that America is
the place that we should be looking and
the big mysteries are in the areas that
were so devastated at the end of the
last ice age up in the north of North
America, the channeled scab
lands in particular and
then the Mississippi Valley.
The whole story of the Mississippi Valley.
Yes,
Mountville as a thousand years old,
but then you can go back to
poverty point in Louisiana,
which is 2,700 years old.
You can go to Watson break in Louisiana,
which is 5,000, 500 years old.
You can go to sites like Conley,
which are 8,000 years old.
The system keeps on going back
and disappearing back into time.
And I think the most fruitful new work
on exploring the origins of civilization
is going to occur counterintuitively,
uh, in the Americas,
the very last place on earth that
archeologists have ever thought
thought to look when it's a
funny thing because you know,
in can 1987,
you know,
I was 17 and I was gang banging,
I got shot and you know,
that I got hit by a 22 and
it as hollow points do it.
Um, it, it broke into three,
three pieces, the hollow point.
And one of them pro punctured
my lung on my left side. And,
uh, you know, they were telling
me, well, you know, do you smoke?
No, I don't really smoke because I
didn't smoke cigarettes. I smoked weed,
but I wasn't going to divulge that
at the time. I was 17 and you know,
and uh, they said, well, you know,
well that's good because you'll never
smoke again. It was like you'd do,
they punctured your lung
and blah, blah, blah.
They thought I was going to have to
work off one lung but in the three days,
you know,
they were able to get the blood out of
the lung and I was able to get it back,
you know, through the exercises
they told me, you know,
to get it back to its regular size and
I've never had a problem since then.
Knock on wood, the piece of metal
out. No, I still got the three pieces.
That's like when I go do my physicals
and they do the, you know, the Mri,
the Mris and the x rays and all
that. The doctors, you know,
sometimes they forget because they
see so many patients. Mr Freeze, um,
these appeared to be
bullet fragments with,
what is that? Well, you just
said it, doctor bullet, frank.
You've seen him a dozen times,
you know, and uh, yeah, I,
I was very lucky. I was very lucky
because, you know, punctured my lung.
And then two of the pieces, one was
by the heart and when was by my spine,
but I was at a Martin Luther
King Hospital in Linwood.
And we call that place killer king because
you go in there for something small
and ended up dying or come out, you
know, gift out or something. So you know,
I wasn't going to allow them to try and
get to those bullets or those fragments
to open you up. Yeah. Not
An ah, cause you know,
they didn't have a great success rate.
What kind of lung exercises they give.
You try to pump your lungs,
but they give you this breathing apparatus
that has like a ball in it, right.
And it has two lines and you know,
it's the first line you're trying to,
they're telling you every day for
five minutes, 10 minutes to blow that,
you know,
not all in one shot,
but like to keep practicing getting the
ball up there and that will then help
inflate the lung and get it back.
So I had to do that for probably
like three weeks. And, uh,
you know, the puncture wound, it
healed itself pretty much. And uh,
and the pieces are still in your
lungs? Not In the law. No, it's, it,
it went passed along. It did shot
passed along. So you know, it's uh,
I got a piece up here and one
off to the side in the back.
Well when it's really cold
due to the nerve damage,
I'll get like stinging like you know,
like when your,
when your hand falls asleep,
the little needles that,
I'll get that here and then, and then
back here where it entered, they had to,
they had to cut right in between a rib
here to stick the tube in to put the hose
into the lung to get the blood out
of the lung. Yeah. As you know,
I was living crazy before I got into
the music. The music saved my life
pretty much. So after high
school I started touring and uh,
that's when like I started
getting my heaviest.
We were eating fast food every single
day, three times a day, never drink water,
soda, only smoking like a pack
and a half of cigarettes a day.
And just on the road
traveling. And then, uh, by 19,
I got up to 305 pounds,
19 years old.
And I remember one night laying down
to go to bed and I just felt my heart
pumping ridiculous Lee. And I was
just like, no way. This is like,
I think I'm going to die.
And like I've woke up in a panic and
weird thing is I got up and I went
outside for maybe like 10 minutes and I
smoked another cigarette and I was
just like, this is the problem.
Like I'm coughing up stuff my hardest
going to give out and I'm only 19 years
old,
you know.
So around that same week is when
I discovered MMA with my brother,
just like watching ultimate
fighter on TV. And so, uh,
I went on my last tour and,
uh, I told the guys like, Hey,
I'm going to go train him and made it
look, oh, you're going to be a fighter,
like you think, you know? And I was just
like, I don't know what I'm going to be,
but I'm going to go train and get
healthy. And they were like, okay, cool.
We'll see you in a couple of
months. You know what I mean? Like,
no one really believed that I was going
to go and actually train and fight.
I told you I, well, he's been like this
big quiet nonconfrontational guys. So, um,
yeah, I went and took my first
class Moyie Thai and March 1st,
2010 took my first Muay Thai class and
then after like a month of doing Muay
Thai,
I started to see progression.
I started to see like my face
was slimming down all this stuff.
So it gave me motivation to
keep going. And then, um,
I remember going to a MMA event,
amateur,
and I saw really big heavyweight
guys going at it. So I was like, oh,
I think I want to do it. I want to give
it a shot. And, uh, so my coach was like,
okay, if you lose a hundred pounds,
I'll like, I'll find you a fight.
And I was like, a hundred
pounds. He's like, yeah,
I'll find you a fight if you
lose a hundred pounds. So, um,
I just kept training within 11 months,
lost a hundred pounds,
and then took my first fight.
And then she felt like every fight has
been until now because it's like now I
have like more of a drive and a passion
for it, but all the way up until then,
everything kind of happened by
coincidence or just like, I just,
I didn't really want to fight, but I had
a lot of people like, oh, you're so good.
Like keep doing it.
And I was the first time in my life I've
ever had people supporting me to like
really do something that was big and I
was a new guy and I was in shape and I
can, you know, girls are noticing
me now. I'm like all either,
my whole life changed within a
year of training MMA. Like wow,
from going to this guy that nobody even
paid attention to, to just like, oh, hey,
how's it going? Are you know,
like, oh, you're so in shape.
And I was just like, oh,
this is weird. It's still weird. It's
only been nine years, eight years,
you know? So everything is
still very new to me. I've only,
my first day stepping on the mat was
like, you know, nine years, years ago,
I got to beat him to be the best, right.
So I need to work hard. What's your,
what's your take on him? You can't
take away what he does in the sport.
What does his outside his personal
life, that's all he say. She say,
I have my words after
to the California stuff.
We went to two 26 or whatever it
was in Vegas and got moved here.
Cause his lifestyle and drug
tests and all the extra stuff,
however you want to code it up, his
past, you know, I'm done. What about,
I had my words there, the fact that
you kept using God and Jesus and this,
this and this and I'm a god fearing God.
Read my Bible every morning and I
don't like the fact that you can,
that he would do that.
I'm like I said I want it now,
but at the time my words was
the fact that he did that.
And then at the same time I
want to interview in this.
I want to thank God and it's,
that kind of rubbed me wrong.
And then we flew on a plane
together and like I said,
I saw the way he was acting
when he came on a plane.
Like we not doing this because of him,
like all that at a time bothering me.
And I was a pent up any and now
something else going into that fight.
That was something on my shoulders because
I had posted something because when a
UFC called me right before I got
on the flight, I was like, oh,
don't come a the way to Vegas now I got
my wife, she's eight months pregnant,
she's 30 weeks, whatever. She can't
travel after this. She's struggling.
We hauled them bags and Y'all call me
and I'll say, don't come this and this.
Go back home. We're gonna fly you out
again. Like I'm not doing this again.
And then when they get to the, well we
can get you here, but we get you Cali,
but we can't take your wife
like what? Like, well you,
we pay your ticket and
coach ticket like no,
fuck that all because Jon Jones is that,
that's what got me mad.
That's what they're trying to save money.
Pretty much flying people because we was
literally walking down the wrong way to
the plane. When they call him
the cheese can I turn around?
But then when we got it like okay you
come here but we can get you to Cali but
we can get to your wife to Cali.
Like my wife is 30 weeks pregnant.
She's here when she's coming like,
well we don't know what to do because
you bought her ticket isn't it?
Like what do you mean you don't know
what to do? Get her nose ticket.
Like I paved my family. What about the
people that's on the way right now?
Like all they got to find their own way
and that made me weak week fight week of
the fight. The thing of the things
that you have to think about, you know,
talking with that,
that's the last thing I was worried about
God and then I get there and they said,
when you get, make sure you got your
workout. If you don't have your workout,
schedule the Pie set already. As
soon as you get there, go do it.
I did mine like a month and a half ahead
of time. I'm like I said, I'm puncturing.
Like I like having stuff done.
Yeah, come get ready to go into Pr.
I'm packing my bags and I get a call.
Oh, you can't come to the API. Why?
John just came in and said he went to
work out so we closed the gym down.
You're not allowed. Oh, y'all
called me two months ago.
Told me to set my schedule
to come ahead of time.
I'm really getting ready to walk to
my Uber that's outside and you say,
I can't come now. Like I sorry.
And then we can do is John,
why can't you work out at the same place
with John's work and not fighting for
the same thing with kindness? It on. I'm
there in the summer and kind of show up.
They're coming into there, but you gotta
leave. Wow. Just rode it. Yeah. Really?
You all gotten kindness? I was car
parked up on the sidewalk. Come on. Yeah.
They have security guards to block
the stairs off and everything.
I don't want no special treatment from
her or from anybody. If I was a champ,
treat me the same. You know what I mean?
Is some people are different, I guess.
I don't know if it's John or his camp
that was doing that or UFC is doing or
security or what,
but it rubbed me wrong that
we aren't equal anymore.
Okay.